well we had a little water free water
from mother nature last night with
thunderstorms we'll look at those
totals in just a few minutes it's always
nice to get rain and boy we sure do need
it because we are so dry
and creating really some dire fire
conditions for us here
in southern nevada we've got 80s out
there but the humidity
is high and those dew points are very
high so we've traded a little heat
for a lot of moisture in the air
thunderstorms rolling in from clark
county last night
packing a lot of lightning again so
dangerous those thunderstorms have
converged
along interstate 40 now in arizona early
this morning
thunderstorm cells bringing the
lightning and strong
outflow winds to up to 60 miles an hour
in our area last night caused some power
outages brought down some tree limbs
and also struck palm trees up in the
northwest valley
so that always is the fear of starting
some fires with this lightning so you
can see the cells are still active in
arizona
and that part of arizona is under flash
flood watches i'll show you
the entire area in just a minute we had
some areas that picked up between
almost a half about five four hundredths
of an inch to a little over a tenth of
an inch
a little more up towards the mountains
and almost four tenths of an inch up in
the moapa valley
moapa valley all along the river and
mohave county northwest arizona under
flash flood watches those start at 2 pm
and go overnight until 5 a.m tomorrow
areas to the west of las vegas still
under excessive heat warnings today but
not las vegas we'll see if we can get it
below 110 today
still looking for the threat of
thunderstorms though through the
afternoon and overnight hours
and again strong winds dangerous
lightning and maybe some heavy downpours
slight chance left tomorrow we dry out
thursday friday
saturday calm down a little bit and then
we get that chance for thunderstorms
coming back we need the rain
just not the dangerous lightning that
goes with it or the flash flooding